auf Frauen sondern dürfen oben ohne
zur Zeit viel Feministinnen warum mit
Frauen eigentlich als Oberteil alle
weggeht und man nicht über das reden
hört
[Musik]
heute zeigen
und was hat das Ganze mit Feminismus zu
das klar wenn der Erfolg zwischen
Barbara oben ohne Party
der Öffentlichkeit
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
aber das ist einfach völlig unklar warum
wenn nicht Set der übrigens in Zürich
Geschlechtsmerkmal so wie bei meiner Art
[Musik]
genau genau passieren
einfach gefragt ein Prost ist natürlich
ein weibliche Brust so
kennen da wir sie immer verdeckt wird
extrem aufgeladen und genau und
begründige schon eigentlich müssen
das sittliche Empfinden wenn ich richtig
informiert ist das südliche Empfinden
nicht verletzt wird und was heißt ist
das genau und ich kann mir schon
vorstellen dass einige Leute eher
konservative Mütter
es gibt Gesellschaft
also ich persönlich finde wenn du
offenbarte liest und vielleicht relativ
knapp bekleidet bist du sicherlich
anders eventuell mega oben ohne
kaufen ich muss sagen
mit so vielen Hochzeit konfrontiert
werden wenn ich da bei mir Essen
geht
Natürlichkeit du findest
ganz wichtige feministische Philosophien
ist immer schon kleidig dort und wissen
wie sie dargestellt hat ist extrem
sexualisiert wurde und wenn du weibliche
Körper oft öffentlichen Abbildungen
immer sexualisiert den findest du umso
mehr ein Nacktheit irgendwie nicht in
Ordnung ich will es nicht der erotisiert
die Körper das ist schon fast immer
Blick ja und Frau Ludwig Düren ja das
kenne ich aber es kennst du ja nein das
andere nicht es ist nicht immer so
sexualisiert wurde
französische Philosophie das Buch
geschrieben
Fruchtbarkeit und später und nachher ist
das sexualisierte oder es zeigt
eigentlich stark kulturell das ist und
das ist nur interessant also eben die
erste Frau wurden Akne das Gesetz rund
und man darf sich dann auch Frauen
am Anfang durch die Irritation Nummer
und das muss ich Lieferanten
irritieren
wie das kulturellen umtüten damit es so
Verständlichkeit wird und das ist
einfach immer
da wo zum Beispiel jetzt Zürich oder
Bären Zeit ab sofort darf man oben ohne
Bade dann sind alle Frauen oben ohne das
wird nicht so sieht das weiß man muss
fehlen anderer Städten in Berlin in
Hannover in Göttingen ist das überall
schon gefallen das quasi Geburtstag das
muss bedecken und gar nicht groß
passiert und darum würde ich sagen hey
ja ja
einfach nur sagen entspannt euch und den
Logo was passiert und vielleicht wird
sie richtig bewegen vielleicht aber
nicht ich werde nicht Bikini Oberteil
abziehen in einer
Coupons
ein einheitliche Regelung
Eis problematisch
entschuldigt und so weiter
genau genau
so ein Quatsch also was heißt das schon
finden
gängiges Beel Hand ins Männerbild
rotieren selber Hand als ob sie so in
Stücke dir sind wo nicht anders könnt
ich find's Thema von der Erotik und
Nacktheit übrigens extrem interessant
weil wo nicht pflichtfachschule wieder
die gegenteilige Position vertretet dass
ich oftmals Nacktheit überhaupt nicht
erotisch finde ich finde eigenartig das
lustige in meiner Zeit besonders
erotisch
oder Hintergrund
ich finde das alles nicht erotisch ich
finde irgendwie umgekehrt sehr oft ist
völlig doch eigentlich sehr
unterschiedlich ja interessiert ist was
findet er der Party alle oben ohne warum
schreibe diese Kommentar warum wird der
weibliche Körper eigentlich so oft so
stark kontrolliert das ist schon
wichtige Frage aber sehr auffallen
sondern wenn man halt die ganze
Kulturgeschichte Religionen und so
weiter der Körper von der Frau sind
irgendwie ein bisschen Angst macht dass
sie sich machen
kontrolliert der Körper von der Frau
will das ist irgendwie ihre Identität
ihre Intimität auch das kann man sehr
gut kontrollieren der Körper während dem
ihres denken zum Beispiel kontrollieren
indem man zum Beispiel ein bisschen
erotisch sind andere Frau und sich
selber Arbeit schützen
kann
wo die Grundform bringen warum muss frau
bedecken
und dann ist natürlich noch
Besitzanspruch dass die andere es in
Teams oder Frau oder nix
anhört
natürlich mit der Frauen auch immer
Verbundenheit von der Familie
von der Tugend und dann wird natürlich
Erotik und Sexualität auf gar keinen
Fall mit deiner Frauen in Verbindung
braucht sondern das Lager mit den aus
ins Freudenhaus also irgendwie bitte
Prostituierte
[Musik]
gesellschaftsseite der überwachen und
Strafen indem man eine Körper sehr stark
kontrolliert also das was eben bei
meiner Militär tril zum Beispiel
verschiedene Institutionen Gefängnis
oder in Schule und das ist schon bis
also dir dann wird natürlich Befreiung
vom Körper also auf meiner Haut
projiziert werden
emanzipativen Begehren sagen wir waren
alle etwas mehr weint aber interessant
finde ja dass wir selbst der BH
eigentlich Ausdruck ist mittlerweile
[Musik]
und da geht es riesigen Diskussionen
zum Beispiel also nackte Brüste zeigen
Adorno ist tot das ist natürlich
Studierende wo gefunden hat
eigentlich das linke Gedanken wenig
weiter gehört
genau und wo den Frauen sind und sich
nackt Musik
natürlich
Aufmerksamkeit generieren
permanent oder und irgendwie ist eine
emanzipationsakt zeige ich bestimme wenn
mein Körper nicht die anderen Frauen mit
Männer aber das Mittel sie um richtig zu
bekommen
das muss ich grundsätzlich wird
verhüllen ich sag nur der Unterschied
zwischen Mann und Frau was ist würde
nicht zu Hochheimer geschenkt mir auch
aber dich hallo denn also FKK wo alle
nackt sind sondern
dadurch dass man nackt Oma läuft
überhaupt nicht so dass es irgendwie arg
geboren ist dass man irgendwie seine
schamwettbedecken
also ich weiß nicht ich finde wirklich
mit dem fkk-zug finde ich eigenartig
dass man dass man das verbindet nachher
mit zu
tätigkeitsteile und so weiter sehen wir
in die neue obere Regale
ganz nackt sind
das Problem ist es für die Person du
Nachtisch oder ist es für die andere
Person oder auch gleich sind und bitte
mir tatsächlich sagen das Thema
Nachtwanderer das ist ja so kriegen das
Kontinent entscheidend
im öffentlichen Raum ich eigentlich
Verletzung von inneren würde willst das
Scham Gefühl verletzt das Argument genau
empfinden oder genau verwende
habe acht freizügig was du siehst
Verhältnis zum anderen schlecht da
belangt hat
eigentlich ist sich alle
der versuche ich sich selber frei zu
machen vom Blick vom anderen also sich
alle
Intimität bewahren und das kannst du
wahnsinnig gut verstehen
im kollektive Gemeinschaften
aber der nietzsche ist zum Beispiel
dass ich mich nehmen muss
sondern sogar vor mir selber näht also
dass sich die Schamgefühle wo alle
kulturell anerzogen sind dass ich mich
von denen
und das ist scheint mir schon noch
interessanter Strip Punkt
muss man sich trotzdem denen abpassen
oder das ist doch der konfliktum hat
soll man das jetzt oder nicht ja als
Fazit Rampe vielleicht zeigen es Bikini
Oberteil ist viel viel mehr also das
Stück Stoff und was nackt oder allzu
nackt ist das entscheidet Frauen
[Musik]
ein Volk mit Feministin Lory Penny und
den volksgleichung zum Thema
Peinlichkeit und Scham